an australian paper the courier male uh
i'm not sure i think it may be brisbane
although i'm not actually positive where
in australia it's coming out of
the headline this is from
six days ago the headline is don't freak
out catch and covet after you are
vaccinated improves immunity
sub headline if you are fully vaccinated
against covet the next step to improve
your immunity may be to actually catch
the virus
now at first pass this looks like
complete lunacy and looks like they're
just you know throwing up their arms and
you know saying anything they feel like
saying at any moment because that has
certainly not been the approach in the
past
there is also built into this the
idea that we are hearing but i have yet
to see any data to support the idea of
quote unquote super immunity wherein the
acquired immunity you get from the
actual disease
is enhanced by also getting the vaccine
and now they're arguing vice versa like
that there is some enhanced immunity
from actually having both exposures as
opposed to just having had the disease
versus just having had the vaccine put
that aside for a moment whether or not
that is true or not it's hard to imagine
what the immunological mechanism might
be but you know you think not okay oh i
think i think it is almost certain that
this is true at some tiny level at some
tiny level yeah okay um but uh you know
that that actually doesn't necessarily
matter here what what does matter is if
if in australia a country that has been
going you know
guns blazing on everyone absolutely must
get vaccinated if what they're saying is
and you know again another thing that is
that this is hinging on is the idea that
having been vaccinated uh
we're now admitting that actually it
doesn't really stop transmission very
much but what what they are saying is
that it will reduce um the impact of the
disease on you may be true maybe not
uh but if that is if if that is the case
they are saying look you're going to run
into the disease they're basically
assuming endemism you're going to run
into the disease just just deal with it
you'll be fine now you aren't
necessarily going to be fine there are
people who've died after getting covered
after having been fully vaccinated and
there are lots and lots of people who
get coveted who do just fine right it
has an incredibly variable effect on
people but to me what this what this
says if we are to take it at face value
is
okay then
vaccinate or not you're going to run
into this what we need is early
treatment what we need is to use the
wide array of drugs that we have
available to us
to deal with treating people as they
show up and
hey it looks like
vaccinated people and unvaccinated
people are both likely to run into this
and really there's no reason to be
pitting those populations against one
another in the political sphere in the
media unless what you're doing is not
does not have anything to do with public
health or about covet at all unless what
you were trying to do is create division
among populations create division among
populations or sell one product um yes
and you know i don't know i don't know
enough about the recent politics in
australia to know but if that headline
came out in the u.s
um i would be responding with okay
clearly we've moved from trump
derangement syndrome to cova derangement
syndrome and there's just there's no
ability to have a conversation
about this that has nuance that says
terrible virus terrible disease
let's figure out how best to move
forward because actually we have shared
fate here people
yeah um i would add to your your list of
things we should obviously be doing you
know
the elephant in the room increasingly is
properly preparing with vitamin d for
example right this is the lowest lowest
hanging fruit on the tree and yet we
don't recommend it which suggests that
we are not actually all that concerned
at the public health level we are
apparently either completely inept or um
not that concerned about your actual
health and we're doing other things i
would say i mean so obviously adding
things to a list that is the simplest
makes it less simple but
the three may be top things on my list
of what
what a country or a world that was
actually interested in public health in
light of this particular virus and
disease would be to encourage
supplementation of vitamin d in any
population where they are likely to be
deficient in it which is to say um the
the higher latitudes your higher
longitudes you're at no higher latitudes
you're at rather and um the more likely
you were to be spending time inside
which also correlates that's one um
recommending that people go outside the
people spend time outside the people get
their exercise outside people socialize
outside not just for vitamin d reasons
but because this virus isn't
transmitting outside still and then
third and this does take resources and
it does take money and it will take time
but in improving
the filtration systems of indoor air
because in you know the smaller the
space you're in
with other people the more likely are
that you are breathing in air that they
have exhaled
this is part of why this is a big part
of why this virus and like all
respiratory viruses are more likely to
spread inside so we need to be focusing
on filtration and you know airlines are
doing it
and yes those are very small spaces and
and very you know very easy to control
but
we have the technology and it will take
some time it will take some money but
this is the way to make people more safe
going forward
every tool at our disposal it really
ought to be um all right so if we can
return for a second to
uh the question of where we are we've
got something that masquerades as
consensus but the point is whatever that
thing is it is coercion dependent
coercion dependent consensus the
implication of it is roughly the
opposite
of
of an actual consensus it's closer to a
hostage video in which somebody
says some things because there's a gun
pointed at them
um
it is also
uh you know
we've heard chomsky's phrase the
manufacture of consent is resonant but
there's a way in which
we are seeing the inverse of many things
and even though it's an easy
extrapolation
we don't
get the implication and so um
the manufacturer of consent is the
mirror image of
um the destruction of dissent which is
what we are seeing those who dissent
about
either
you know sex and gender issues and claim
that there's some substantial difference
between males and females
right or those who
claim things against the public health
narrative are
punished severely resulting in a much
tinier number of people willing to say
these things out loud and in fact lots
of people will lie to themselves
so you know the destruction of dissent
is is uh
is key to how this
works
um
so i'm not sure how much how much more
there is to say i did have a thought
about uh in light of the role
that the
you know that we have we have seen
played by youtube in particular
it did occur to me that there is room
for
uh us to do youtube a favor and
we've done a little pro bono
work generating a slogan
for
the people who generate the um
the community guidelines the slogan is
going to be something like
youtube community guidelines
because you can't handle the truth
yes yes all right i think i think that
works
[Music]
you